at last week's pmq's kirst armor tried
to ferment back bench Tory division on
Northern Ireland but after a largely
positive response to Rishi sunak's new
deal with the EU that topic now might
prove fruitless so instead the labor
leader hedged his Bets with a more
scattergun approach
[Applause]
building is going to fall to its lowest
level in 75 years if he scrapped his
non-dom status he could start to fund
better child care and the prime
minister's tactic was to respond by
lambasting Labor's policies
stop making inflationary unfunded
spending commitments stand up to the
vested interest in the unions and back
our minimum service level it's the same
old labor party always running out of
other people's money
that final Barb was a line Margaret
Thatcher used in 1976 now Richard zunak
also managed to Pivot from answering a
question on housing to attacking Labor's
position on energy it is an absurd
policy but it didn't escape the
attention of a Commons class he seemed
to point this out to the speaker who
then said this what
because of the noise I don't think the
premises hearing the questions because I
do think it was on host building Pierce
after more than one hundred thousand of
Matt Hancock's WhatsApp messages from
his time as health secretary were leaked
to a newspaper the labor leader also
asked when we'll find out the truth
about the government's pandemic response
the coveted inquiry has already cost the
taxpayer 85 million pounds and hasn't
heard from a single government Minister
yet he has mentioned it one or two times
before that he was a lawyer in a
previous life that there is a proper
process to these things it is an
independent inquiry
and one kirst armor question about the
economy unexpectedly mentioned the 1980s
TV comedy drama Alfie design pet about
British Builders leaving the UK to work
in Germany if the tour is limp on in
government we're going to see a
generation of young people learning to
say I'll be the same pet in Polish
aren't we
the smps Westminster leader didn't seem
convinced
later Stephen Flynn returned to his
favorite topic of brexit allowing him to
attack both of the smps Scottish Rivals
Mr Speaker let's be clear what the Prime
Minister said yesterday was the EU
single Market access will be a good
thing for business now of course that's
in contrast the leader of the labor
party who said in December the EU single
Market access would not boost economic
growth does it hurt the prime minister
to know that the labor party believe in
brexit more than he does yeah the
important thing to note is to avoid a
land border on the island of Ireland
between North and South elsewhere there
were questions about a refugee choir
singing at the king's coronation if it
turns out that any of the refugees
taking part in that choir have arrived
here on small boats or from a safe Third
Country should they be deported to
Rwanda before or after they sign for the
king and a mention of one of our own
investigations the Prime Minister may be
aware of Sky News investigation and
report today on the over-the-counter
sales of nitrous oxide or laughing gas
to children and young teenagers one
alarming aspect is the change in the
size of canisters from 8 grams to 620
grams the Prime Minister responded to
that by saying he was concerned that a
review is underway the government he
said had asked for it to be accelerated
and he will then consider next steps